natürlich wollen viele menschen jetzt
aus der angst heraus sich schützen
kaufen maske egal ob sie jetzt
tatsächlich laut experten braucht nun
nicht wir waren mal in einer apotheke um
auch zu sehen für wie viel geld
tatsächlich jetzt solche masken verkauft
werden
eine atemschutzmaske bezug also wir
haben nur die mit der filterfunktion
dieses ffp 1 und die kostet jeweils 16
euro dann was 16 euro warum sind die
denn so teuer
die sind so teuer ich habe die auch
teuer eingekauft und schützt die ausfuhr
ohne die hilft auch gegen viren also
gegen viren und bakterien die ist mehr
als einmal zu verwenden und wenn man die
nach jedem benutzen außen den des
infizierten die ein bis zwei wochen
locker benutzen
16 euro für eine maske wir haben jetzt
gesagt bekommen der einkaufspreis liegt
eigentlich bei unter 50 cent was sagen
sie also wenn sie jetzt sehen wie teuer
diese masken an menschen verkauft werden
die einfach aus angst sich schützen
wollen und die frage jetzt an mich gegen
annan sie bei das ist ja auch okay dann
fange ich vielleicht mal kurz an das ist
um verschieden das ist schlichtweg
unverschämt ja wie gesagt haben wir
haben bis vor kurzen und das ist bis
anfang februar brutto für die masten 50
cent bezahlt ja und wir sind die am ende
in der produktion auch nicht wert und
auch bei den 50 cent beim die hersteller
ja noch verdient das problem ist halt
die nachfrage treibt die preise nach
oben
wir zahlen als krankenhaus mittlerweile
auch schon bis zu sieben euro brutto für
diese masken die lieferung die wir jetzt
vom von der hessischen landesregierung
bekommen haben ist in dem sinne für uns
kostenfrei
aber was da im moment passiert ist
einfach wirklich ja das ist einfach und
sehr das ist unverständlich das ist
unsäglich und da machen leute profit in
der krise und das sollte nicht sein
wie sehen wie das bei ihnen geht
natürlich auch am ende darum ob sie geld
mit den masken dann verdienen können
oder nicht
ja ich glaube bin absolut echt ansicht
dass in so nach basel mittleren preisen
geschäfte gemacht werden sollten das
sehe ich ganz genauso aber ich möchte an
einem punkt etwas differenzieren
gegenüber meinem vorredner wir haben uns
in den letzten jahren ganz
offensichtlich darauf verlassen dass wir
uns ausschließlich mit asiatischer ware
die in billiglohnländern hergestellt
wird mit solchen produkten eben
entsprechend eindecken wollen oder
können und dass ein mit relativ geringen
offensichtlichen vorräten
jetzt muss man einfach so sehen
natürlich wird auch die fertigung jetzt
teurer
wir produzieren eine näherin bei uns in
vier minuten eine einzige maske in der
gleichen zeit kann ein automat der
irgendwo in einem entsprechenden land in
asien produziert 480 masken herstellen
das alleine und und wie entlohnen unsere
leute wir bezahlen unsere leute nach
tariflöhnen
mit allen entsprechenden gesetzlichen
vorgaben das können wir natürlich nicht
vergleichen mit einer solchen produktion
das möchte ich einfach zur
differenzierung dazu sagen
das heißt es gibt hier schon preise und
preisunterschiede
das heißt wir werden ob dauer natürlich
mit anderer solchen manuellen fertigung
auf keinen fall wettbewerbsfähig sein
das war aber auch gar nicht die
intention die wir gehabt haben sondern
es war die intention kurzfristig zu
helfen
auf der einen seite kurzarbeit in
unserer produktion zu vermeiden dass die
leute weiter arbeiten können die
kapazitäten ausgelastet sind und auf der
anderen seite wie eben entsprechend
damit dann auch den markt versorgen
können nur ist es so dass die politik
hier sehr sehr wenig aussagen macht die
eine sicherheit und geben weil ich habe
in den letzten zehn tagen zwei automaten
die eine solche kapazitäten ermöglicht
gehabt hätten
nach china gehen lassen müssen weil ich
es aus meinem unternehmen nicht
verantworten kann eine solche maschine
momentan zu investieren weil mir die
sicherheit nach absatzmengen nach den
entsprechenden preisen und auch die
investitionen mittel die ich aus meinem
kerngeschäft nicht abziehen kann und
mein unternehmen zu riskieren in einer
solchen phase wo wir nun umsatz machen
und da greifen sämtliche bemühungen die
ich auch in die politik nach bayern und
auch wenn die bundesregierung
eingesetzter laufen kommt wäre da bin
ich sagen ohne die hier würde denn eine
maske bei ihnen dann am ende kosten
ja wir reden jetzt weise die zwischen je
nachdem zwischen 1 euro 20 und 2 euro
liegen